- C'est la météo qui décidui dée
du moment où Mathieu Lachapelle
va sortir braver la tempête.
et le verglas comme d'autres
scientifent après
les tornades.
MATHIEU LACHAPELLE doctorant
- C'est un radiometre, c'est
un instrument que l'université
du Colorado est venue installer
ici.re
fois que les instruments prêtés
par Envipar Envipar Envipar Envt
se tourner vers le ciel
de Sorel-Tracy. Pendant sixrantt
au département des Sciences delé
les précipitations quand elles
Celsius.
- Nous, on s'interesse
météo, donc vraiment
les situations où on n'est pas
sûrs du type de précipitations.
Donc, ça va tu tomber en nei pl?
- C'est un travail d'équipe ave,
réparties dans la Vallée
- On est à quatre stations
en même temps, donc on va
tous en même temps à 7 h.
Puis là, l'avion va pouvoir
representer en 3D la température
dans l'atmosphère et adapter
- Dès que les précipitations
mixtes s'annoncent, on lance
les ballons sondes toutes
- Ok, donc il est 7 h,
je vais le lâcher.
Si les ballons peuvent
c'est ce qui se passe sous
les couches d'air chaud à trois
ou quatre km qui importe.
JULIE THsc. atmosphère, UQAM
- Avec l'avion de recherche,
ça nous dit qu'est-ce qu'il
y a au-dessus de nos têtes,
l'atmosphère, qui fait que
maintenant on a de la neige,
du verglas ou du grésil.
- L'étude américaine Wintre
Lac Champlain et la Vallée
du St-Laurent, cette derniè
étant un point stratégique.
- On a comme un petit bonus,on s
que les autres endroits.
- Les données qui es, auront
des retombées bien concrètes.
Par exemple, de meilleures
prévisions pour guider
les travix d'équipement.
- Ça prend juste quelque chose
au-dessus de zéro ou en-dessous
de zéro  une grosse
difference. On pense juste
aux trottoirs.
- Les grands-parents de
d'héberger et d'alimenter
les instruments cité.
LISE ROBERGE-LEMIRlle
- Ça intéresse un peu tout lemos
me posent des questions.
- Puis les ballons ça quand
les ballons?
- Toujours!
- Curieux destin : le petit
garçon q
la crise du verglas, est revenu
lques semaines.nant, je suis ict
j'étudie la pluie verglaçante.
- En six semaines, il y a eu
10 épisodes de précipitations
comblés.e-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Sor